more and more americans say they are
getting their news from youtube now this
can be interpreted a lot of different
ways one of the interpretations is
simply that it's a matter of platform
changes tons of media of legacy media
companies the three-letter networks etc
they're on youtube so it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're getting
your news from different sources when
you get it from youtube you might just
be watching youtube clips instead of
turning on your tv but getting the exact
same stuff on the other hand there is
also a contingent that believes
incorrectly that analysis shows like
mine and commentary shows like mine on
youtube are news shows now i make it
very clear that i do commentary and i do
analysis and save the occasional
news that comes from an interview i do
i'm commenting on news
the write loves to take advantage of the
fact that many people don't realize the
difference between news and commentary
to make them think that the opinion
stuff they're watching is actually news
and that's very bad